are you looking now and i'm not trying
to make you give anything away
yes you are i'm not i'm sure everybody
does i can't maybe
we honestly have not decided we're
really trying to figure it out right now
you're in the middle of deciding whether
it ends or it doesn't it's it's what
story do we tell
to end a show this iconic
how you know how do we do it that's
ellen pompeo talking about the future of
grey's anatomy in a new interview with
cbs sunday morning i just want to make
sure we do
this character and this show and the
fans
i want to make sure we do it right
ellen's latest interview comes after
fans speculated that season 17
could be the last following the surprise
returns of tr knight and patrick dempsey
the returns are all part of a dream
sequence meredith is experiencing as she
battles covet 19 on the medical drama
is ellen pompeo going to be okay on the
show
is there hope for meredith we know she's
entering this covid trial
and i'm a little nervous i'm a little
nervous too no there's there's
there's hope there's got to be hope i
mean uh
as far as i can see there's there's hope
and she
kind of represents both the the sheer
the terror and the very real uh
and reasonable fear we have of what's
kind of been washing over this country
but also our fight our our
stick-to-itiveness
our preparedness and and it really does
put in perspective
you know live your life now form your
relationships now
and and people remember how you made
them feel i don't think there's anybody
in tv history that's made
people feel as much as meredith gray
that was jesse williams with et just
weeks ago
he also opened up about what lies ahead
for the long running series
he has suggested that this could be the
final season
though where do you stand i don't i
don't think so i think it i
look i i don't know but
i think the show is too important to
go out without a damn parade other grey
stars have also recently told et
that season 17 likely won't be the end
either
do you ever think about closing this
chapter
and moving on to something else i know
from a creative standpoint there have
been many
like oh this is how the season would end
this is how the series would end
conversation and then they all end up
you know
new because of a myriad of reasons
because
the network's not ready the studio's not
ready the fan base isn't ready the
numbers are too good
i think that collectively they create
they've decided you know what we're
not going to put an end on it we're just
going to wait and see
especially in light of what's happening
right now it's like do we want the last
season to be about coven
or do we want it you know us to be able
to put some nice ribbons
around it with rainbows and balloons and
things
meredith is entering a covid
trial thanks to richard's decision
what should we expect from this
storyline moving forward
usually i'd be able to tease kind of
something about that
question but this is the first season
that i
have no idea i don't know what's going
to happen to meredith gray i really do
not
that makes me worried makes me worry too
i mean she has said that they've thought
about how the show could potentially
end yeah you think because all these
people are coming back
and they are being so secretive that
this could be the last season
i think listen i think that every season
could be the last season i think that
i've always felt that because we're on
the air for 17 seasons so i'm like this
will be the last season like and then
and then we keep going on and the fans
keep watching and showing up
you